this is uh I mean this is It's Your show
is really a phenomenon it's a hilarious
show and it's got a very unique voice
and this has got to be a nice thing for
you this thing's exploded it's pretty
cool
passionate fans can I should I talk to
you into this thing can I talk directly
into this or yes yeah yeah that doesn't
work yeah that's just for sure it's just
I don't know why it's a very weird
microphone but we'll get it fixed all
right uh upgrade it you this is what I
love one of my favorite stories in
Showbiz is when when people do something
it's new and different and they have no
support and they sort of make it on
their own which is really the story of
this show you guys had an incredibly low
budget when you started yeah uh and how
absurd did it get I mean it was pretty
pretty absurd like um it took us two
seasons to realize we could get the
network to pay for an office you know
yeah so like I would call Rob and Glenn
be like do you want to work at your
house today or do you want to write our
television show at your house and we'd
call our manager and say is anyone using
your conference room we really need to
write the show and you know we'd pay for
each other's lunches like all right
who's paying for lunch today I guess I'm
I'm paying for lunch and then we
realized
you know that's stupid this is uh this
is the television show they should pay
for that yes and then they were more
than happy to let you just go that way
for your own lunch right uh yes I do
you don't have to do that season season
three no I do actually it was made very
clear that I had to pay for myself
you get to Tyler Perry's status
oh I can't wait I'll buy you some
lunches would you would you accomplish
yeah I also Andy and I need a place to
work during the day
yeah yeah basic cable man you'll get
there all right this is
tell me more
you know one of the things uh there's a
lot of things I really like about your
show but one of the things I really like
is that your characters are always all
of you guys are always scheming on how
to to get rich and you have really
stupid ideas that are very entertaining
uh for example uh on on one of the shows
uh I believe you guys invented Kitten
Mittens yeah which
let me tell you something if if you want
a hit basic cable television show
put some mittens on cats because that's
going to be funnier than human beings
will will ever be I mean you kind of
can't compete with it no so probably
yeah yeah well we actually have the
footage here I believe we have Kitten
Mittens clip let's take a look here
[Music]
thank you
there's no winning no that's it I mean
that's it